[Música]
y
culminó en madrid la cumbre de dos días
de la otan a los líderes de la alianza
atlántica se fijaron como objetivos
hacer frente a la guerra en ucrania e
incrementar su presencia en el indo
pacífico para contrarrestar los
intereses de china en la región
nueva polémica en la corte suprema de
justicia de eeuu el máximo tribunal
restringió la capacidad de la agencia de
protección ambiental para regular las
emisiones de carbono lo que entorpecería
el proyecto del presidente joe biden
para luchar contra el cambio climático
fin del paro en ecuador el gobierno y
los movimientos indígenas firmaron un
acuerdo que pone fin a 18 días de
protestas y bloqueos y que acoge
parcialmente las demandas de los
manifestantes
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz
empezamos en europa los jefes de estado
y de gobierno de los países que integran
la organización del tratado del
atlántico norte otan acordaron el
concepto estratégico de madrid' al
término de la cumbre de dos días en la
capital española hacerle frente a la
guerra de rusia en ucrania e incrementar
la presencia de la organización en el
indo pacífico para contrarrestar los
intereses de china en esta región son
dos de los objetivos principales de la
alianza
mientras finlandia y suecia reciben la
bienvenida a la otan rusia y china-
ahora se consideran una amenaza para la
misma así quedó definido en el nuevo
concepto estratégico que marcará la hoja
de ruta de la alianza para los próximos
diez años en una decisión militar
histórica que no se registraba desde la
guerra fría la organización acordó
reforzar el flanco oriental con 300.000
tropas de cara a la guerra rusa que hace
de ucrania y los países miembros se
comprometieron a dar un paquete de apoyo
integral a largo plazo para que quieren
frente a la agresión de moscú
juntos estamos desplegando más activos
con todos nuestros en todos los dominios
por tierra aire agua virtual y por el
espacio estamos reafirmando que nuestro
compromiso es sagrado y el ataque a uno
de nosotros es un ataque a todos y por
eso defenderemos cada centímetro del
territorio de la otan
la región de lindo pacífico será la
nueva vía estratégica de la otan para
frenar ambiciones políticas económicas y
militares de china un país que ahora
representa un reto para los miembros de
la alianza en una zona geoestratégica
que incluso ya se habían planteado como
objetivo eeuu australia y reino unido-
con el pacto august en septiembre del
año pasado la colaboración en el indo
pacífico incluirá nuevas tecnologías
para la ciberdefensa seguridad marítima
y la lucha contra la desinformación
china está aumentando sustancialmente
sus fuerzas militares incluidas las
armas nucleares intimidando a sus
vecinos y amenazando a taiwán vigilando
y controlando a sus propios ciudadanos
mediante tecnología avanzada y
difundiendo mentiras y desinformación
rusa los jefes de estado y de gobierno
dejaron claro que la crisis económica y
alimentaria que afecta a varios países
no es a causa de las sanciones
occidentales sino por los bloqueos de
rusia a los puertos ucranianos y
aseguraron que aunque apoyan a ucrania y
cada centímetro del territorio de la
otan la alianza habilitarlo hace parte
del conflicto
y no hay optimismo sobre las
conversaciones entre eeuu serán
destinadas a bloquear el acuerdo nuclear
de 2015 después de un encuentro de dos
días en qatar el enviado de la unión
europea dijo que el evento terminó sin
el progreso que el equipo esperaba desde
la capital iraní nuestra corresponsal
catalina gómez ángel nos entregó
detalles aquí en teherán nos reunimos
como hama marandi que es asesor del
gobierno en estas negociaciones
nucleares y le preguntamos cuál era de
sus puntos que son importantes para
teherán para volver a revivir este
acuerdo y si tenía que ver con el asunto
de levantar las sanciones contra los
guardianes revolucionarios como
argumenta washington
en
los estadounidenses a través de los
medios y centros de pensamiento aseguran
que el asunto son los guardias que están
en la lista de terroristas de los eeuu
en respuesta dijo que si washington
remueve a esta organización de la lista
hoy todavía no habría acuerdo porque
para irán ese no es el asunto principal
el asunto principal son las garantías de
que eeuu no traicionará a irán de nuevo
como ya lo hizo en 2015 irán busca la
implementación del acuerdo e irá no
quiere que esas garantías sean puestas
en su lugar para que los estadounidenses
simplemente no puedan destruir el
acuerdo de nuevo e irse queremos
teherán siempre ha dicho que la
condición principal para volver al
acuerdo nuclear es beneficiarse
económicamente y que se levante en la
totalidad de las sanciones sin embargo
los críticos del gobierno radical en
teherán acusan de estar torpedeando
volver a este acuerdo y no querer
realmente volver a hacerlo le
preguntamos al profesor marandi cuáles
son las condiciones en teherán en este
momento y cómo ven la situación global
actualmente
hay que tener en cuenta que el mundo
está cambiando irán está vendiendo su
petróleo y a muy alto precio irán no
tiene petróleo suficiente para
satisfacer la demanda de sus clientes la
relación entre irán y rusia ha mejorado
los rusos necesitan a iran la relación
con china también ha mejorado los
europeos han reconocido que necesitan el
acuerdo no hay petróleo adicional en el
mercado como macrón le dijo a bailén es
así como los estadounidenses y europeos
necesitan un acuerdo e irán no pide nada
extraordinario lo que pide es la total
implementación del acuerdo firmado en
2015 y la confirmación de que eeuu no
traicionará nuevamente a irán
la delegación iraní ha dicho que seguirá
en contacto con la unión europea para
seguir conversando sobre este acuerdo
sin embargo no hay ninguna fecha para
próximas conversaciones lo que ha hecho
que el real la moneda local en irán
caiga nuevamente frente al dólar y que
el pesimismo vuelva a imperar en las
calles de la ciudad el parlamento de
israel voto su propia disolución una
medida que envía al país a las urnas en
noviembre por quinta vez en menos de
cuatro años y el lápiz ministro de
asuntos exteriores y artífices del
gobierno de coalición saliente se
convertirá en el primer ministro
interino después de la medianoche del
viernes
el parlamento israelí knéset fue
disuelto llevando a las quintas
elecciones en menos de cuatro años y el
nombre del primer ministro naftalí
bennett no estará en la carrera
electoral
quiero hacerles saber que no tengo
intención de presentarme a las próximas
elecciones pero seguiré siendo un leal
servidor de este país al que he servido
toda mi vida como soldado oficial
ministro y como primer ministro
tras varias dimisiones benet anunció el
colapso de su coalición de ocho partidos
en la semana pasada tras sólo un año de
mandato pero aseguró estar orgulloso de
sus logros
manning gracias a dios' dejó atrás un
país próspero fuerte y seguro el
gobierno bajo mi dirección ha conseguido
hacer en un año lo que muchos gobiernos
no han logrado en un mandato completo en
cadencias yemen bennett ha tenido el
poder a su ministro de asuntos
exteriores yair lapid que dirigirá un
gobierno provisional por lo que los dos
intercambiaron sus sillas en la knesset
se espera que la pita haga campaña para
mantenerse en el cargo de primer
ministro
como su principal rival en los comicios
del 1 de noviembre se espera que se
postule el primer ministro que estuvo
más tiempo en el cargo benjamin
netanyahu a pesar de los entramados de
corrupción en su contra netanyahu afirma
que su alianza con la derecha los
ultranacionalistas y los partidos
ultraortodoxos ganará las elecciones
aunque las encuestas señalan que él
también podría tener problemas para
conseguir una mayoría parlamentaria y
ayudan continúan las manifestaciones
ciudadanas en las calles de diferentes
ciudades de ese país africano los
manifestantes rechazan el golpe de
estado dado por los militares el pasado
mes de octubre que depuso al gobierno de
transición entretanto continúan los
llamados de la comunidad internacional a
la junta militar en el poder para que
reestablezca el gobierno de transición
que a su vez debe convocar a elecciones
generales
jornada sangrienta en sudán al menos
seis personas murieron este jueves
durante las protestas contra la junta
militar que gobierna el país
desde el derrocamiento de omar al bachir
en 2019 la imposición de un gobierno de
transición y posterior destitución de
este en octubre pasado el país ha vivido
una crisis política constante en los
millones que han salido a las calles
desde el 6 de abril de 2019 han tenido
como objetivo lograr un estado civil
pleno donde la autoridad sea el pueblo
que esta revolución sea popular y que
regresen los soldados a sus cuarteles
durante las protestas se ordenó bloquear
la señal de internet y el corte de las
líneas telefónicas las autoridades
militares tomaron medidas drásticas para
que las multitudes no llegaran al
palacio presidencial a pesar de la
represión las masas no cejaron en sus
reclamos
la gente tiene que confiar en sí misma y
nunca retrocederá hasta que sus
objetivos se cumplan y el pueblo sudanés
tendrá la victoria sobre los generales
la víspera 13 representaciones
diplomáticas incluyendo la delegación de
la unión europea instaron a las
autoridades militares a garantizar la
libertad de expresión y la protección de
los civiles en las manifestaciones según
el comité de médicos de sudán gente que
se dedica a contabilizar y atender a las
víctimas los fallecimientos se elevan a
109 desde el inicio del golpe
y en ecuador después de 18 días de
manifestaciones y tensión la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas y el gobierno se dieron
negociaron y alcanzaron un acuerdo en
torno al precio de los combustibles que
tendrá una reducción de 15 centavos en
lugar de los 40 centavos exigidos por la
conaie están hacia el presidente lazo se
dirigió a la nación apelando a la unión
escuchemos el momento de curar heridas
de superar la división entre
ecuatorianos y unirnos en un solo
objetivo
reconstruir el ecuador
debemos recuperar el tiempo perdido
trabajar fuerte
especialmente por los más vulnerables
vamos a emprender juntos la tarea de
transformar la paz que hoy hemos
conseguido en progreso bienestar y
oportunidades para todos
vamos a hacer del campo y de la
ruralidad prioridad nacional
y a partir de hoy la corte suprema de
eeuu tendrá una nueva jueza y es la
primera afroamericana se trata de
aquitania brawn jackson quien prestó
juramento judicial este jueves y en un
momento crítico a raíz de decisiones
controvertidas tomadas por este órgano
sin embargo su llegada no afecta a las
fuerzas en el supremo
con su esposo sosteniendo la biblia y
sus dos hijas mirando que tan y brawn
jackson prestó juramento judicial el
jueves juró ante el juez que sustituye
steven baker que se retira a los 83 años
la mujer de 51 años es la primera
afroamericana en servir en la corte
suprema de eeuu y cuando el senado
confirmó su nominación en abril rindió
homenaje a los que le ayudaron a allanar
el camino
y estoy aquí en nombre de las
generaciones de estadounidenses que
nunca tuvieron nada parecido a este tipo
de oportunidades
la jueza jackson tiene una larga e
ilustre carrera jurídica y es experta en
justicia penal y disparidades en las
sentencias recientemente prestó servicio
en el tribunal del circuito de
washington y es la primera ex defensora
pública que llega a ser jueza
braun jackson se incorpora al tribunal
en un momento crítico con la fe del
público hacia la institución en un nivel
bajo tras su controvertido fallo para
acabar con el derecho constitucional al
aborto su juramento se produce el mismo
día en que el presidente bailén criticó
al tribunal por su comportamiento
escandaloso en relación con esa decisión
lo primero y más importante que debemos
hacer es dejar en claro lo escandalosa
que es esta decisión y el impacto que
tiene no sólo en el derecho de la mujer
a elegir qué es una pieza fundamental
crítica sino en la privacidad en general
pero para aquellos que esperan que la
jueza jackson incline el tribunal hacia
la izquierda su incorporación no cambia
el equilibrio ideológico
los conservadores mantendrán su mayoría
de 6 a 3
y seguimos en eeuu porque la corte
suprema de justicia tomó otra
contundente medida esta vez en materia
de medio ambiente
el máximo tribunal restringió la
autoridad de la agencia de protección
ambiental para regular las emisiones que
generan el calentamiento global la
medida recibió el apoyo de los jueces o
seis jueces conservadores y la negativa
de los magistrados liberales previamente
conversamos con javier sierra portavoz
de la organización ambientalista sierra
club quien nos comentó qué repercusiones
puede tener esta medida en el resto del
mundo teniendo en cuenta que eeuu es el
segundo mayor emisor de co2
y estados es el segundo el segundo mayor
emisor de co2 pero históricamente es el
mayor de la historia
lo que estamos viendo ahora mismo es
obviamente no salen de
eeuu tiene que dar ejemplo de eeuu tiene
que ser un líder mundial en el combate
con el cambio climático no podemos
volver a los cuatro años previos a la
actual administración en la que nos
convertimos en un paria internacional
por habernos incluso hasta renunciado al
acuerdo de parís
la ciencia nos advierte que se nos acaba
el tiempo para combatir la crisis
climática nadie debería hacerlo aún más
difícil para que el gobierno use las
herramientas efectivas para proteger a
las familias y las comunidades del país
como les indicaba antes la ciencia es
clara para 2030 tenemos que reducir en
un 45 por ciento las emisiones de
combustibles sucios y para el año 2050
eliminarlas por completo lo que nos
estamos jugando aquí es ni más ni menos
en el futuro de la humanidad
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
pero los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web www puntos 24 punto com para
seguir la actualización de nuestras
noticias gracias por acompañarnos
continúan con toda nuestra programación
[Música]